et en pleine crise du pétrole l'école se
met également aux économies d'énergie à
sainte-marie-aux-mines en alsace la
commune a fait construire un
établissement qui utilisent des énergies
renouvelables un choix écologique donc
qui permet également de valoriser les
ressources régionales correspondance de
christine bost et vergély ados ici la
forêt vosgienne s'étend à perte de vue
alors pour sa toute nouvelle école
maternelle sont mariées l'une a opté
pour une structure bois en sapin des
vosges plancher charpente et façades
le bâtiment de 800 m² fit l'unanimité
est allé en quoi la foule est très belle
et
le fait d'avoir d'avoir mis beaucoup
beaucoup de bois
ça nous paraissait normal dans une
colline que l'apu boisé d'alsace et
comme le bois il a à profusion
la commune a décidé de l'utiliser la
nouvelle école en bois sera chauffé au
bois avec cette chaudière automatique
alimenté par des copeaux de bois
stockées dans un silo
coût de l'opération 400 mille euros soit
le double d'une chaudière classique mais
grâce à 80 % de subventions la commune a
pu faire le choix d'une énergie
renouvelable tout en maîtrisant sa
facture énergétique
le calcul a montré qu'en l'espace de
quatre à cinq ans ces équipements
pouvait être amorti
rien que par le fait de l'économie que
nous réalisons au haut niveau du
combustible entre le bois et le fuel le
chauffage au bois
c'est aussi et surtout une façon de
valoriser les sous produits de la forêt
proche
c'est du bois qui reste à courir
d'autres dans les forêts ou qu'ils aient
brûlé de façon sauvage dans un coin
cessé de toute façon on voit qu'il n'a
pas d'usagé
aujourd'hui et qui pourrait trouver des
usages modernes avec les chaudières dont
on dispose aujourd'hui les forêts
alsaciennes à elle seule pourrait ainsi
fournir deux cent dix mille tonnes par
an de bois de chauffage sans abattre un
nouvel arbre